recording in
progression for some reason so I may
turn off my video
but we are here
for
program preview of the Purdue University
digital marketing boot camp
we're having video problems uh
instructor Bernadette Chambers is with
us but she can't start her video
my video is
not working well so I'm going to just
keep our videos off and let you focus on
the presentation
and of course as I mentioned Bernadette
Chambers is here
and she is
uh an internationally recognized
marketing training she's an entrepreneur
uh is the CEO of her own company the
socialite hive uh
experienced in Consulting to many
different
multinational corporations on their
social media and digital marketing
strategy
and um
we're very pleased to have her here
today and as one of our senior
instructors so welcome Bernadette
hello everyone
um so we're going to be talking about
digital marketing today about the career
field I'll be asking you a few questions
uh the audience along the way in polls
um we'll describe what the program
offers how it gets you job ready
and we'll share with you the enrollment
steps and a special bonus offer for you
for being here today
Bernadette will take your questions
toward the end so please put those into
the Q a function within Zoom
uh so we can keep track of those also
um you can if you're on the streaming
service put those into uh the chat or
the comment box
and those will um
get transferred over to us so we'll be
able to ask those of Bernadette later
but with that I'm going to go ahead and
start we'll talk about careers in
digital marketing so Bernadette if you
could talk about how
the digital economy is transformed in
the last few years and how digital
marketing has become
so very very important
yeah absolutely so as you guys know we
are coming out of the lockdown ages
um we are moving a lot into digital
transformation and some of those other
subject matters and so with that a lot
of companies are
now understanding from the standpoint of
maintaining the new status quo of being
present digitally we have almost
undergone just a complete digital
transformation inside of all businesses
all Industries more and more companies
are seeking media buying that curtails
the activity because like
um I mentioned before even on the
consumer side people are still in their
um post pandemic habits such as online
shopping
um streaming streaming on more platforms
and so companies have to meet customers
where they are the expectations are
different the way that we communicate is
much different and so on and so forth
and so what I'm seeing on the horizon
now is companies
shifting towards the new digital age and
keeping the customer focus Centric to
that
yeah I mean the
we've
been my favorite quote from the pandemic
was about a week or two in when I went
to a
an online webinar with the Venture
Capital company and one of the
executives said if they had told us we
would have to go all to work from home
we would have said that will take six
months and 10 million dollars in budget
and we did it in three days with no
budget
so we've we've transformed our world to
um
people who
were reluctant to buy things online
kind of were thrown into the deep end of
the pool
um but that just you know had them join
the rest of the world that was already
using online shopping and
remote
face-to-face selling and that type of
thing so
digital marketing is
a huge part of our world today and going
forward and pretty much every business
needs
digital marketing presence
even if they have brick and mortar
stores
the other favorites other favorite story
is about the American fast food chain
Wendy's
uh which discovered after they
implemented their their mobile app for
non-contact ordering uh that they had a
new Treasure Trove of marketing
information about consumer Behavior so
uh the side effects of of this
transformation have been incredible
so you know the the career opportunities
go into so many different fields can you
uh talk a little bit about what these
are
absolutely and so one of the things that
when we do these program previews that I
like to mention is think of digital
marketing almost or liken it to almost
the medical field right you have a
general practice doctor then you have
maybe a obstetrician a pediatrician a
gynecologist all of these different
specializations right as much as people
would like to believe there is no one
person that can do all nine of these
responsibilities trust me I've tried it
does not work
so once you have gotten introduced to
all of these Concepts which you do which
you are introduced to all of these
Concepts inside of the program you must
then figure out exactly where or what
trajectory that you would like for your
career to go and if you were to do a
LinkedIn search with these exact
job titles you will see that the job
availabilities are much different now
out of these you do need to have an
understanding of all of these in order
to Be an Effective marketer why because
you will be working with people in
conjunction with that so it is very
important to know
that it is not just one Mastery it is
quite a few masteries built up inside of
a total process
with the digital marketing manager
overseeing all of these which is why
it's at the top so you have here search
engine optimization which is SEO again
that is almost a 24-hour job it is
highly competitive because you are
trying to leverage traffic that is free
you have an email marketing manager that
once you have built up an audience
there's a specific way to communicate
with those people content marketing is
on the surge because more and more
people are interacting with content in
order to make purchasing decisions
social media strategists need to create
content so it's almost like they are
content creators as well as strategists
on how to send the brand overall message
PPC planner and digital advertising
managers those are pretty hot in terms
of specializations because once you have
learned what your brand and your
audience and where they are located in
order to expand your reach you need to
be able to pay to play and then of
course e-commerce which had a huge boom
between 2020 and 2023
um with the height of it being 2020
there was a lot of Brands I'm pretty
sure you noticed on the consumer side
that just sprung up out of nowhere and
now they are brand favorites and then of
course website marketing manager who is
solely responsible for the website so
again in this program you learn what
those people do and this is an evergreen
process I've been in this business 10
plus years and I can tell you
that this is not something that you
learn and then you put your books down
and then you're free to go you need to
challenge yourself to learn even more
and just to recap as you saw in the
center of that bubble there's just a
whole
variety of skills that touch on all of
those different roles is
Bernadette explained
um if you're a Content marketer you need
to understand how to optimize the
content for search
you need to understand how to use web
Analytics
to check on the performance of your
content
to understand website optimization to
understand how the content is presented
on the website and how that interacts
with the
user the consumer all of these things
touch on each other so
having a comprehensive
program that allows you to pick up all
of these skills it's really a valuable
thing so I'm going to ask a question of
the audience
what has stopped you to date
from taking a digital marketing
certification and getting into
type of career
we assume you're all here today because
this career field interests you excites
you
so
we're curious to know why you haven't
done something of this type before
and I will leave this open
foreign
for about five more seconds
please get your answers in if you're
watching on a streaming service you can
use A B C or D in your comments
of course you can pick more than one
all right and I'll end the poll
result
the biggest concern is not finding that
comprehensive curriculum and then the
second biggest concern is not feeling
that you'd end up with practical
experience that you'd be able to show
off
to demonstrate your new skills so
we'll talk about
those aspects of this program
this is the digital marketing boot camp
Purdue University puts on in conjunction
with meta there's content provided by
meta and it's delivered by simply learn
that's why we're here to talk about it
we are the delivery partner
and the QR code can take you to the
program page but this is a six month
program we say you need to devote about
10 hours a week because they're a Live
digital classes live virtual online
classes that meet weekly with
instructors like Bernadette
those are what four hours each a day on
the weekends Bernadette usually
yes it's four hours so it's a four hour
class on the weekends once you
um get to Capstone it goes down to
three hours okay and and is that like
for on Saturday four on Sunday or is it
uh just one of the two days it's four on
Saturday four on Sunday when you get to
Capstone it's three on Sundays okay
and the curriculum we'll talk about uh
is comprehensive it covers the skills
that we've just talked about and it uh
includes on the same platform the
ability to do your case studies and
projects in that same online environment
so from your desktop from your laptop
you do everything you need to do in the
course
you can access on your mobile device
much of the content
um especially some of the pre-recorded
videos your instructors will ask you to
watch to prepare for their classes
and you can fit any of those other than
the class meeting times everything else
is on your own schedule so you can do it
whenever it fits into your lifestyle but
you have 24x7 support So if you happen
to be
up at three o'clock working on a project
because you can't sleep and you find
that you've run into some type of dead
end you can contact someone at
get help with that
so
at the end of the process you receive a
certificate issued by Purdue University
and simply learn
we jointly certified that you have
completed the program
finish all the core courses successfully
done the Capstone project
along the way you have elective courses
including master classes from Purdue
instructors of master classes from meta
instructors
uh you can you will receive an exam
voucher to receive meta certification
and you'll become part of the Purdue
alumni association
so that you can have networking
opportunities going forward
uh
I just want to mention Purdue University
I think Bernadette has done a number of
batches of
people through different programs with
Purdue
and
uh a very well established and very
reputable uh Public University in
Indiana
uh it's been around for 150 years
uh consistently one of the top public
universities has produced Nobel Prize
winners
and it's it's one of the places that uh
if it's on your resume people will
recognize the name
but we're very proud to be associated
with them we're proud that they chose us
to be their delivery partner
so
we're also proud that meta
chosen to partner with us they produce
content for the course including ask me
anything sessions
including master classes given by meta
experts and preparation for their
certification exam so you end up not
only with the Purdue simply learned
certificate that you can earn the meta
blueprint certificate as well
the join of this program the
requirements are very open
but you need to have a high school
diploma need to be 18 years of age
you not have to have work experience
although work experience is always
helpful
do you not have to have a marketing
background although that's always
helpful so it's very very open to
anybody who's got a high school diploma
and wants to be in digital marketing has
a passion for it
um so
I am going to run the next poll
this is
how much experience do you happen to
have
you got a feel for the audience let
Bernadette know who's
listening
and we'll leave this open
for about
10 more seconds
let's see the numbers are still changing
and I'll close in three
two
one
well Bernie that this is very
interesting because we have a
about a third almost 40 percent of the
audience are people who are currently
studying probably working on their
bachelor's degrees
um and then we have a sizable number a
third of the audience who have more than
five years of experience
a broad range here
yeah that's definitely interesting
um one of the things that I want to say
to the folks that have that five year
um
experience in working this industry has
changed so much in a matter of two
um and it's going to change even more
with the introduction of chat
so that's something to really really
think about if you blink you miss it so
when I know when I instruct these
classes in a lot of the other
instructors that instruct these classes
we instruct them from the perspective of
real live on the job training experience
live examples live things that's
happening right now so you're not
getting you know uh regurgitated content
that is no longer relevant to the field
some of the concepts if you have the
experience you will be familiar with but
we have tons of students that had
experience going in and felt like wow I
learned so much more
to add to the experience that I already
had yeah that's a great lead into the
discussion about the curriculum because
it's built to take you through
a set of modules in a step-by-step
fashion that builds from the basic
understanding
on through gaining each of the different
skill areas
and culminating in that Capstone project
that
as you tie all of those new skills
together in a final project can you take
us kind of up to up this stair step sure
absolutely so that first class is always
going to be your introduction you're
going to learn what you're going to be
learning how the landscape has changed
and just have a general uh introduction
and a discussion that's leading to that
then we go into each class it's going to
have a subsequent project so you're
going to be doing some of the nuances
some of the researches around SEO and
what you will notice is you will notice
that there is a
kind of leading or build up to each
class so each class has its project what
you did in the project from the class
before is relevant so it's always
helpful to choose one company because
that next class that you're going to be
in you're going to be building off of
what you did with that when you get to
SM sem or search engine marketing that's
your paid marketing piece then you'll be
creating social media content and
driving that portion of it all the way
up until the Capstone project where you
will put all of these elements together
that you have been exercising over the
course of the class
um one of my favorites out of this whole
set out of this whole program is I
absolutely love web analytics I'm kind
of an analytic nerd and there are
exercises that you're actually able to
do that surrounds now G4 it used to be
Google analytics but they are sunsetting
Google analytics so now you'll be
learning exactly how to navigate G4 and
it really really is a Hands-On designed
to be something that you can work
alongside learning not just sitting and
hearing instructors like myself lecture
the whole time
yeah that's a great point because uh
that's the the main
difference between our Boot Camp style
of learning and other programs that
expose you to pre-recorded material only
and then take you through
um online tests
there's there's no feedback in those
kinds of programs this this lets you
interact directly with the instructor
during the live classes and interact
with them indirectly in between and
along the way you do the projects using
the various tools
so that you not only
um
get exposed to them and learn what the
names are and have buzzwords for your
resume you have actual experience
projects that you have done with these
that you can point to and show off to
people and say yes I this is how I used
for example LinkedIn ads
this project and so you can have
confidence that I can do that for you
um
so this is one of the the great things
about the program is that you learn by
doing
and
gain
practical experience that you can put
into your portfolio and demonstrate to
other
people
and then the Capstone project as uh
Bernadette has said can you describe the
process Bernadette that a learner goes
through
um to build the Capstone project what is
that last module like
yeah so the Capstone project is kind of
an extension of what you've been doing
the entire class there are virtual Labs
that are available to help you to put
all of the different elements together
but you're kind of working on the
Capstone the entire time and then the
requirements
are adjusted a little bit so that you
can add additional feedback additional
information to the concepts that you've
been working on but essentially it is a
shorter class it's only three weeks with
the three hours and basically you're
working with the instructor to put those
projects together within the boundaries
that they have set for the class so some
of it you're absolutely going to already
have knowledge of
um because you've been working on it
throughout the entire time some of the
concepts you will have to adjust
at the end of that you have a project
that you not only submit for for grading
um kind of like your final exam but also
a project that's in your portfolio
show off to people so
um
I think
you have the ability to uh
share your screen and let me so we'll
check that oh you are you able to uh
do that one panelist can share at a time
who can share hosts and panelists now
you can
and
let me check one second
so I provided that that we're not having
technical difficulties with zoom because
we've had the technical difficulties
with our our video today
but if Bernadette Bernadette is able to
share her screen she'll be able to take
you through the live tour of the
learning environment
yep I mean why a quick second sure
my mouse is like all over the place
so I have to Reign it in
have some machines
slowly take over our lives
yeah this one's not too bad it's just
the I have so many screens and so much
my mouth is oftentimes on someone else's
screen so it's like okay
can you come back to the world please
thanks
all right share screen
all right if everyone could yeah
yes we can all right excellent
I try to make this bigger so everyone
can see
all right so as you can see here
you would have your program and your
program would look very similar to this
so you would have
postgraduate program in digital
marketing if you go to the program you
will see all of the courses laid out
some courses are electives but it's laid
out exactly in this fashion once you
have completed all of the courses and
the requirements this certificate will
unlock it will have a Purdue branded
signature and things like that to show
that it is credible and it is
credentialed by Purdue
when you go to one of these classes
let's just say the welcome class we'll
just go here
you will have your self-learning modules
that are listed on this side and then
you will have the live class access and
once you've completed all of those
components then you will have your
certificate located here now honestly
going through the self-learning
exercises are really good so that the
class can focus specifically on the live
examples the application of the concepts
so those of you who will be moving
forward into the program this is not
just this is not the whole program it's
simply to help you to get all of the
basics out of the way get your refresh
your content so that you're able to
really dive into asking relevant
questions that can help you with the
application of those Concepts you also
have your notes here you can take notes
add labels things like that live and
they store here forever and ever because
you'll have access to this always
then you have your community so whatever
batch that you're in the communities are
there to assist you in talking with
others who have been through the program
so that you can get insight on projects
get insights on what the expectations
are even you know network with folks who
already have other assignments or other
jobs right
going back you also have the help tab
anytime that you're having any sorts of
issues you just simply submit a request
and they're able to help you with issues
that you may have with the class as a
whole but that's essentially where what
you have if you have a uh if you have
opted for any electives you will see
those here and this is where you will
also access your master sessions your
master classes and things like that
um and of course after this all of this
is completed you will be able to
download your certificate which I
absolutely love when my students go in
and they share with me that they have
achieved their certificates and they are
moving on to other projects or other
things so that's pretty much in a
nutshell the LMS and the platform so
that you can see how it would look if
you were able to enroll in the class
and just to clarify that um
it says uh
postgraduate program that's the parallel
program we went with Purdue in digital
marketing today we're talking about the
digital boot camp much of the same
content so
uh the learning management system works
exactly the same way
um in fact it works exactly the same way
across all of our simply learned
programs
um so that
if you continue on in your learning
Beyond this one program uh you'll be
familiar with and able to access all of
those through the same familiar
environment uh Professor ginsely is the
program advisor for Purdue University he
oversees the curriculum
and ensures that we are delivering it up
to the standards of Purdue University
so this is uh
definitely a Purdue program delivered by
simply learn
we can talk a little bit about learner
outcomes
yeah
here are a few people who have gone
through this type of this digital
marketing training
um
and they've been extremely successful I
mean this is one of many many dozens of
uh success stories that people have
shared with us
um
but I like what ewart says about uh how
he was able to use what he learned to
Leverage
uh a new job as a digital marketing
manager
um
what Corrine says about the fact that
she's continued in her education through
many courses and in several years so
um we're very pleased that Ernst Young
I have said that 90 of learners
achieve their goals with our programs so
we also offer you
a career assistant service which extends
for six months after you earn your
certificate this is important because if
you're using what you learn to leverage
into a new position whether that's
internal to your company or whether
you're looking out into the world for a
first job or a promotion and a new job
with a new employer we provide support
for that yeah it comes in several
components one is access to ongoing
education through webinars and career
events that we run for free
that you can access same way you're
doing today we have the options of the
different real world projects that you
do in the program to build up your
portfolio and that portfolio I think
Bernadette has said have you had the
example Bernadette of a
learner who was able to use their
Capstone project
as the sample that got from the new job
is that correct
or that's on mute
yes I actually had a
um I had a student that in a recent
Bachelor took uh right before uh 2022
ended and she was a um she was a
marketing manager of a pizza oven
company and she actually was working in
real time
um alongside of the program to adjust
and optimize some things and seriously
recently reached out to me to let me
know that the things that she learned in
the class actually helped her to get a
promotion
um in a new role that was centered
around
um
optimization website optimization and uh
paid marketing media buying
so that was a really really
um just live example of you know a use
case of a student actually working
alongside the company she was already
working with I have had students in the
past that went on to work for General
Mills a lot of folks um went on to work
for a center of contractors so there was
definitely some things that uh that
helped with absolutely yeah that's a
great aspect of a program that runs in
parallel that doesn't require you to
take time off of work but allows you to
fit it into your work schedules that you
can apply your new skills real time in
your job so that's great
um the third part is the job assist
services for Child by Talent Inc or uh
us students best Learners we offer
access to their job portal exclusive
jobs through their employer network
with confidential and uh privacy
protected application
so that your employer doesn't
necessarily see that you're looking at
new opportunities I think the other two
parts are
um even more valuable one is the resume
review and rewrite service which is
um
gives you access to a professional
resume writer and in today's environment
resumes have to go through an automated
tracking system AI bot which is going to
look at the content of your resume and
match it against the
job description so you need to have your
resume in a format that's readable by
the system by the AI bot
and where the information is presented
in a way that the bot can readily
understand the connection to the job
description that's kind of an art form
but the thing that really makes it a
true art form is the fact that your
resume still has to be appealing to the
human eye because once you pass that
automated filter
it'll land on somebody's screen or
desktop and they still need to it needs
to catch excuse me
needs to catch their eye
and induce them to call you for an
interview and then that brings up the
the interview prep service where you're
going to go through
several rounds of interviews for any new
job
may have to do phone screens with HR
you'll have to do technical screens with
people asking about your specific
skills that you would apply to the job
and you'll have to
talk with supervisors and managers who
will assess you for your cultural fit
for your
suitability as a member of their team
and the interview service will help you
prepare for each of those types of
interviews so that's a really
we think very valuable service again
these Services don't guarantee that
you'll get a new job they're not a job
guarantee program they're a
job assist program to help you with
your job search going forward for six
months after you earn your certificate
I mentioned the webinars you have
various experts who will talk to you for
an hour about the state of Technology
the opportunities in a given field
um how to plan out your career how to
use a career and job search tools
all of these are free and available to
you lifelong
and as we've mentioned many times the
Capstone projects themselves are part of
this uh process uh here are several
different domains that you can choose
from you can choose to do a travel
project the financial service project
consumer goods or hospitality and you'll
get a problem statement like this
that you'll then spend the last three
weeks in that Capstone module working
with your instructor to develop and
build your Solutions so
a program fees for the
boot camp project are seven thousand
dollars
which you can Finance over time zero
interest financing over 12 months 616 a
month
and as I mentioned there's going to be a
special bonus for those of you who are
here today you have the ability to claim
a 500 discount just for being here at
this webinar so if this is something you
want to do
um
you can get 500 off of that
total price and you do that by reaching
out to us at ask us at simplylearn.net
so at this point I'm going to ask
basic question are you interested
in
enrolling in this boot camp
I'll leave this question open for about
20 seconds so we get pictures coming in
and get your answers in I'll close the
poll in about
five seconds from now
which is five four three
one
and
two-thirds of our audience are
interested in enrolling so I'm going to
share with you how that's done
and forward the enrollment steps are
extremely straightforward
um I think Arjun 's here to share in the
chat with you the uh email address and
the link to the program page
um ask us at simplylearn.net is where
you submit your application again
mentioned to them that you came to the
webinar and are claiming your 500
discount they'll take an application
from you but it's again the requirements
the prerequisites are very open
so they may
ask you some questions about your
aptitude and your commitment to taking
the program evaluate that because we
want to make sure that people who are
going to make this investment are
willing to make the investment of time
as well and
put in the effort to be successful
there's no reason to get involved in a
program that's going to last for six
months and
acquire Financial investment unless
you're committed to succeeding so that's
the main thing that the application
review focuses on and then we'll send
you an admission offer
um
for those of you who said you are
interested
how soon would you like to
enroll
we have batches that start
on a very frequent basis so
almost monthly
and they'll leave this open for just
another five seconds
simple question
and here is the result
so about sixty percent of the audience
wants to start either immediately with
classes that might start
end of February early March or within
the April May time frame so that's great
and of course we recommend that you
contact us at ask us at simplylearn.net
right away if you are looking at
um
something further out do contact us now
at ask us simplylearn.net
get any lingering questions answered and
you can stay in touch with us we'll keep
in touch to let you know when the future
cohorts are
so at this point uh I guess at this
point I'm going to keep that slide up
because we don't have anything else to
look at
because of our video issues today
um
but I'm going to go into uh
looking for the questions
see check to see what has come in
see oh hold on a second
um
bear with me there's going to be an
interruption
are you able to hear me Bernadette
I think he went away I can hear just
fine
okay are you now able to hear me
yeah I can hear you just fine okay
um so we have Gremlins today that are
invading our systems and I got kicked
out of Zoom for a moment so at this
point again I would like to to go to our
questions
apologize for that delay
and
q a here
I don't see any open questions am I am I
having dropped out my questions of
appeared
so Bernadette do you see the questions
in the Q a
um let me see if I can go over there
really quick
there was one that says
um
notice simply learn video content has
examples dating back from 2005 to 2018
scares me Purdue any different
um the content is often
um updated
um there is nothing that she will be
learning that was 2018
uh everything that we are talking about
is related to well it's happening to
date
um with the exception of 2000 uh in 23
but the last time I taught this class
all content have been updated and
relevant to what was going on here and I
believe that the last update was created
in 2021 so we're still well within the
confines to still use that content but
live instructors are always going to uh
provide examples that are relevant to
the time
um
did you show the boot camp digital boot
camp classes we went over that portion
when we did uh the different content we
can't show the full classes
um because of copyright and things like
that but we can definitely uh we
definitely showed those structure and
the structure that we did on the slides
this year and
um it says uh do I have to do Centerline
courses in Purdue putting my bypass
since we learned out edit content just
to produce the program is produced so
the learning management system that you
are utilizing is through simply learn
but the actual live courses with the
live instructor is the delivery for
Purdue so like let's make that clear
distinction the content that you're
learning that's the self-learning
portion that portion is not outdated
those are foundational principles
especially if you are have no experience
um and we had a question here how does
the program compare to other colleges
and universities uh you'd have to make
that assessment but Purdue is as I
mentioned
one of the world's leading universities
certainly one of the leading
universities in the United States
and um
there the uh
I just said this program is a Purdue
program that is delivered by simply
learn
um so
um if you want to compare it to
the person named a few other
universities uh if you want to compare
it to those you would have to do
kind of a side-by-side comparison
between the other course descriptions
from those universities but
um our
feeling is that this is one of the best
digital marketing training programs
available and our methodology
gives you really the best chance of
success so we're very proud of that
I also wanted to add Stuart really
quickly because I was seeing kind of a
theme here when you go to university
typically you have to purchase books
right in the admissions typically are
not updated they're updated every three
years
in some universities because we have a
learning management system we have the
ability to not only update that content
um in real time but we're also able to
present it away from just relying on
textbooks or online books or things like
that so again the whole purpose of the
self-learning content is to basically
refresh yourself it is foundational
content but the actual instructor is not
teaching you from that we are teaching
you from live examples live experiences
we do have slides however those slides
are just a guide for us to be able to
give you ongoing examples that you can
take with you in real time and utilize
with job opportunities or jobs that
you're currently in
I'd also like to mention that we work
with a number of different universities
and we work with them because
universities have recognized that while
their academic programs
prepare students to be critical thinkers
and give them the theoretical and
knowledge of the foundation for the
fields of study
they don't necessarily
equip them to apply those in the
workplace and so they've come to us
to help them
craft their programs and deliver them in
a way that people who are working can
access them without having to
take time off of work and also that the
the skills that we're transferring are
not just knowledge based or Theory
Theory based but are practical uh do
learn by doing this so
um it's it's an interesting Trend and
you you take a look around in the
education Technology field you'll notice
that many universities
have programs that help them Translate
the skills the knowledge and the theory
that they have into the skills that
their students need big gap between
graduating from college and having the
skills to apply in the workplace we're
helping them close that Gap so that's
one of the
the great things about this program we
have a question from an attendee who
asks about military or veteran discounts
for Saunder discounts please contact ask
us at simplylearn.net and they will um
be able to answer that question for you
about available discounts of course you
do all have access to the 500 discount
for being here today in this webinar
um
Bernadette did you see any other q a
questions
[Music]
I only saw
if that's if that's all we've got uh
yeah most of them are most of them are
questions about costs and discounts and
things which yeah yeah and the costs are
as we covered the the program fee of
seven thousand dollars but you do get to
claim that 500 discount for being here
today
um we had a question about whether
they're a weekday programs I don't think
that does does this boot camp have a any
batches that are you know weeknight
classes instead of weekend
during the day and then they have they
have something that's like right at the
tail end of the week and then they have
some that are on the weekends yes
um that has been a conflict for me
because I'm not available during the
week but it's it's it's evening time
yeah
so it's like a Friday for like master
class and it's very short and then they
have
um some courses that are solely uh
provided on the weekend okay
and I hope that answers uh all of our
questions if if we haven't been able to
answer all the questions
um because of my technical issue uh
please reach out to us at ask us at
simplylearn.net
and we'll try to get those things
answered for you and at this point I'm
gonna
share the last poll question for our
audience
yeah claiming the host
but look at that
what are the weekend hours Again by the
way somebody asked the weekend hours
generally are eight to twelve Pacific is
that correct
correct yeah
again uh do you need assistance with
enrollment and with this question I'm
going to ask if you want to get a
proof of attendance certificate for
today's session
um
click yes and we will send one to you
and I'll leave this open for just about
uh
five more seconds here
the numbers have stopped changing much
so
here's the result 75 percent of you said
yes
again we will send out a proof of
attendance for you and also we'll reach
out to you to answer any questions and
help you with enrolling
and with that I want to thank
Bernadette for being so generous with
her time and knowledge today
thank you Bernadette
no problem it's my pleasure
and I want to thank my colleague Arjun
for helping keep track of
what's going on
during the webinar
yeah
thank you and I want to thank all of you
in the audience for being here today
and sincerely hope that we can